[Musique]
ce jeudi 28 juil le président du
département a visité deux exploitations
agricoles et ont fait l'objet d'un
financement par le fait à terre au fonds
européen agricole de développement rural
et s'est tout d'abord rendu à la sca
chemin d'eau à saint gilles les hauts
melvin akino de la société matinée a
fait visiter l'exploitation et décrit
les changements apportés grâce au fait
adhère
c'était de nous a permis de construire
deux bâtiments de 2,2 pour faire des
poussins alternatif dont qui se trouvent
dans les roues de deux boutons rouges et
devront changer la ligne de production
qu'on a ici et qui nous permet de gagner
du tendre et surtout d'améliorer le
quotidien et le travail des salariés le
département autorités de gestion en
charge du feader à la réunion aussi un
volet leader destinés au développement
économique des territoires des eaux dans
ce fonds feader nous avons aussi un
volet leader destinés à l'aménagement
des eaux de la réunion c'est un petit
peu le le un levier supplémentaire qui
est proposé afin de permettre aux hauts
de la réunion à la ruralité réunionnaise
de garder son dynamisme et continuer à
proposer à la population qui vit dans
ces territoires des activités de
proximité la deuxième visite de la
journée s'est déroulée chez muriel et
vincent dambreville installé au tévelave
qui grâce aux aides ont pu créer leur
fromagerie aurait été difficile
vu le montant des investissements au
départ comment on commence jeune
agriculteur n'a pas forcément énormément
de moyens
il faut avoir un projet bien ficelé et
pouvoir convaincre les organismes
financiers dont les banques et et après
par la suite monté les dossiers avec les
accompagnateurs pour le financer
cyrille melchior salue la qualité du
travail et les investissements réalisés
le département et la fois accompagné le
service les élus avec notre budget pour
accompagner ces familles réunionnaises
du monde agricole et je dirais que c'est
un pas de géant que nous avons fait
durant ces dernières années parce que
dans beaucoup de domaines et bien petit
à petit on gagne des parts de marché ou
gagnent en autonomie alimentaire au
galsi qui ont également dire tout en
ayant des produits de qualité des
produits de terroir
[Musique]